so you got some energy you can take off
by making this little out but there's a
limit to what you can be there because
if you turn them around you got to worry
about that we close off your your entry
so the closer you get to him
keeping that initial disturbance which
is here the better okay but that's gonna
require a little bit more energy on your
part so you can do a couple things one
have the ground pot get yourself in
there and projector in his center second
thing is softness on your hands yes you
have you got to have that you going all
all contest
it's brony pushing him and him pushing
me but the second he goes when he goes
to push it I don't which there's no
struggle he pushed it on me
pushy there's no struggle for art it is
there's no struggle on my part
you can you guys understand that so
that's happening even though that's a
struggle even the tension in your arm is
this photo so Softimage you're going to
get a better response
[Music]
and as you advance you should take less
you should take more and more out of the
armed control you're really interested
in this basement
[Music]
and you won't have to do as much of that
just attack the base softness hundred
joists off
he falls into the cushy notice that my
technique is shrinking that's another
sign you're getting it we can this is a
marginal luxury look at all the math
space should be over
[Music]
you saw inch
okay let's try
[Music]
Hey
hey watch if you're over rotation so
when you come in here you get it this
foot must continue the forward progress
cannot go here this it's actually going
backwards and a lot of you guys are
doing it there you come an inch you know
you need a rotation because you need his
head to go around you what's your goal
like this you over rotate it and you're
actually out undetected so if I'm on
this wall right and if I start to bring
this foot this way
I'll leave my arm one leg look I came
off the wall do you guys see that so
that's kind of what you're doing and
you're you're losing the initiative of
Dede me
so it'd take more I'm gonna kick him in
the face here boom
[Music]
different you're out of the technique
you can't kick them in the face
okay if this foot had gone forward they
try to so we're talking about softness
but my arms not relaxed and he captures
there it's that I have the same
extension on let's say he pushes a nice
day so you can see how you know there is
a force a struggle there you see that he
pushes hard the same thing you see
there's a struggle there what we mean by
softness is I keep that same structural
integrity but I don't push it into him
and as he keeps going I keep it at that
zero point you got you understand since
this isn't he comes in you know you like
you're gonna be smashed
save it save structural integrity but
keep it so that it's never being pushed
off keep it at zero don't ask to the
struggle whoa so a lot of ways of doing
that distel right Roley passing it to
the other arm the vector of entry all of
that stuff is allowing you to not create
a struggle but going to sleep and not
have an extension that's not one of them
okay
and the entire technique is that the
entire technique is how do I work zero
pressure how do I keep things at zero
[Music]
usually it's psychological like you look
you want to control him so you push them
then just accept and then the technique
will you'll find it you want him to come
in it's on you're pushy and then he
starts to fall right
you wanna me
hey let's try to get alright and a
couple of things is how to move so back
to the young ground path okay so you got
to push your knee to your toes then that
becomes a positive angle and guess what
I'm going to do here I'm going to do
this a push your knees to your toes and
so that becomes a positive angle a lot
of you are going out in like that
there's no weight shift shift shift
shift and that's why you have no power
going in that down at that final entry
second thing is the whole technique is
about
Aiki which is we're gonna describe it
today as zero pressure I'm not adding to
the struggle and I'm not yielding to the
struggle I don't go overly in or overly
on you guys understand the entire
technique is that way so my whole body
my hands by inside to my skin are all
doing that okay
well that means he has to have some
young to him otherwise
I would keep entering okay you see and I
especially at the bottom so when I come
around in here you better give me a
reason not to just go down and go to
mouth do you understand or coming in
right and he better give me a reason not
to be able to do that he keeps his
extension you got it so he starts
rolling the other way yeah boom going
something else and usually that will
happen because you're beginner Luke it
goes unconscious as their bowel starts
to be taken
they don't regain consciousness till of
peak after they hit the ground but you
should feel that you should not train
your body for the form train your body
for the energy okay if you feel this go
down or you feel the structure roll the
other way this is your technique just as
you can't prove nugget nugget will
improve bootcamp so boom shift shift and
you'll see us that's a lot of energy
right if I shove this down that's not
like hitam I'm adding to the struggle
so I'm going to go around the energy
move move we're going to go this way
in DC his body will disappoint and I
continue my strategy just guide falling
bodies
[Music]
go down as a unit don't go down like
this you're breaking your organization
[Music]
unit that includes breath
so that moment right here that my weight
should be on their ass because it was on
there as we were going down so I don't
go like this
okay just odd okay he's not tapping out
because it hurts and he's not tapping
out if you can't move he's letting me
know yeah your weights on my own okay if
he doesn't feel weight hookah feels the
in space oh okay I didn't do that one
right
[Music]
so don't sit there ten years waiting to
tap you should feel it or you should
fill it let's go try to take the hour
manipulation out of it each rep try to
sophisticate your heart
[Music]
go again Chris keep going keep going so
you don't have the activation angle on
your knee pad
[Music]
you over-rotated your over rotating your
using the arm Tristan
[Music]
so you were adding to the struggle your
over-rotating still not armed
it's a lot of arm it's okay if they're
smaller and weaker than you but it's not
the art there's no armpit area
maybe that's why you need the arms if
you want to get go down you're gonna do
that right if your mind goes through
there grab you're going to do that you
need to think more universally strategic
so it's much easier to find a guy who's
got no face it's much easier to find a
guy who is falling down got it it's
really really hard to control someone's
by just controlling their arm so let's
inverse that let's control their center
and let that pull on the arm and then I
just stay up with the arm that's the
concept but emotionally if you're going
to do these other things then your
performance eeling goes way down okay so
you have to try hard not just at the
level of I'm going to pin them because
to you that probably means get their arm
your effort must go into not using the
arm go into attacking the base
that's what I mean trihard there okay
some other things
remember how short the technique can be
it just needs to be one body length so
watch how much you're you're walking
across the back
[Music]
I'm just working on the boom in me
that's the main part okay try harder
I'm asking you not to meet the arms so
if I don't meet the arms here
theoretically I don't even need a
bulldog today to find this technique
just move everything in place
boom
[Music]
let's try it